on this particular mission in March of
2021. it was Rob and Tim's turn at the
controls and while they knew they
weren't going to be the first to go that
deep well they found a way to make
history anyway and you hold the record
for what full deepest beer in history
the hot and thus deserves the best
Goldberg
served best at the bottom of the ocean
[Music]
now that was back in September when we
took you to perhaps the most remote spot
on the planet Challenger Deep at the
bottom of the Western Pacific Ocean a
spot deeper than Mount Everest is tall
think about that we were aboard the
limiting factor a really deep sea
submersible vehicle that is the
brainchild of Adventurer Victor vescovo
now we introduce you to him back then as
well but after meeting the guy we
decided we needed to take more of an
in-depth look with Lee Cowan
Victor the scope he spent his life
living somewhere between the edge of
Heaven
[Music]
and Dante's Nine Circles with him at
bottom
his achievements include diving to the
deepest spot in all of the Earth's
oceans
as well as blasting into suborbital
space aboard a blue origin rocket and he
did all of that in the same year I
personally have never been bored I think
in my whole life so there's always
another challenge another thing to push
he looks the part of an adventurer his
blonde hair pulled back in a
swashbuckling ponytail having not quite
caught up with the gray in his beard
proud Texan born and raised and made a
fortune Fortune private equity and
hasn't been shy about using his money to
fulfill dreams he's had since he was a
little boy I guess all kids grow up to
want to be an adventurer or something
but so few actually different right yeah
I think on the Curiosity scale mine's
like at 11. probably the most dangerous
thing that my parents ever did was they
gave me a bicycle when I was quite young
and that was it I just went off and
explored my city and all that to the
Great Horror of my parents because they
didn't know where you were often no but
I always came back
every Adventurer has their own motives
for taking The Road Less Traveled Fame
bragging rights money but for viscovo
this Wanderlust can really be boiled
down to him being just kind of a gentle
perfectionist if I do something I want
to be decently good at it when he was in
his 20s almost on a whim he decided to
climb Mount Kilimanjaro the highest
point in Africa he did it and that
feeling got him thinking for me it was
just hey how high can I go to answer
that question he began making his way to
the tallest mountains on all seven
continents one by one he conquered them
including the tallest of the wall mount
Everest not the hardest he says but it
was the most frustrating I got about
halfway up to Camp two and I got
frostbite on my hands and it would only
have gotten worse the higher I went it
would have put me and my teammates at
risk so sometimes you just have to
accept
the reality and say it's just not your
time what's the point of exploring he
says if you don't come back to tell the
tale I'm not Reckless I'm very judicious
in how I assess risk and then I do what
I can to mitigate it and I think that's
why I'm still here
returned to Everest on his second
attempt he did make it to the summit the
scovo also skied to both poles North and
South putting him among the very few who
have achieved the Explorer's Grand Slam
achieving records is is nice it's it's
recognition but it's not the real
motivation instead he says he's driven
by a sense of the possible true he has
the money to make the possible more
likely but that's still no guarantee
when he first set off to conquer the
ocean depths he had to build his own
submersible to do it once he realized
what he had it opened even more
exploring opportunities like trying to
see if he could find the deepest
shipwreck in the world it's the smallest
wreck you could probably try and find
the USS Destroyer Escort known as the
Sammy B sank in 1944 over some of the
deepest water in the Philippine Sea no
one had even tried to look for her
before but the scovo found her sitting
on a Ledge
so cool because even just 25 meters away
you see nothing but ocean
and then relatively quickly you can just
start to make out the faint outlines of
something that is not organic and not
rock and then you start seeing the
unexploded ordinance ammunitions on
board and you're going okay I need to
step back a little bit perhaps not
surprisingly he's been down to the
Titanic too a dark solitary and sobering
visit that was really special though
being in my own submersible being able
to
be at the Titanic and just just get out
all the Tails yeah just me in the wreck
you know he's done it all well people
's weren't even about A Journey to the
Center of the Earth
Victor viscovo says he would sign up for
both he's confident that the reward of
Discovery will always outweigh the risk
of not being interested enough
to even look
that I believe is what makes us human
that is why we have the position we do
on this planet
we have the ability to invent technology
and to train ourselves to allow us to go
to places where we have no business
going but that is the essential quality
of being human
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Lee Cowan
at Sea in the Western Pacific
I I respect what he's doing I I just
part of me says can we solve the
problems of the world before we go off
plan sure but what better to do with
your money but push limits explore and
see what's out and I love it he's so
enthusiastic about it but let's get our
act together here on the surface all
right